ich bin heute perfekt getarnt bei der
bundeswehr hallo beim fernsehen krieg
ich nur verträge für eine saison aber
beim bund kann ich mich noch fürs leben
verpflichten
mal sehen ob das was für mich ist
hier wird ja gerade der ernstfall
geprobt hat man denn im ernstfall
überhaupt bereit alles aufzubauen also
portionen hinzustellen dass es so gut
aussieht und so gut klappt wird
natürlich extra für den tag der offenen
tür alles so aufgebaut dass mir das
trocknen und botschaft transportieren
möchte jetzt möglich daten stellen
also wer praktischer wenn in feindesland
tag der offenen tür wäre sicherlich
einfacher können wir das ganze auch vor
gehoben mit mehrere male
[Musik]
bei der bundeswehr da sind die soldaten
oft so gut getarnt man weiß nie steht
grad ein soldat vor einem oder nicht was
jetzt auch manchmal dass die kollegen so
gut getan sind dass sie die übersehen
bei uns nicht nur aber könnte dann der
gegner sich auch erkennen könnt ihr
natürlich könnte er sollte aber nichts
ist so ein tag der offenen tür nicht
auch immer ein gefahr dass die soldaten
entkommen können daher natürlich
vorposten den verkehr hier nur in eine
richtung und zwar nur ihren steuern
können
eine frist der kommt nicht mehr raus ich
wäre sie waren offensichtlich heute
schon da
warum frage ich einfach mal wo ist denn
der stand mit dem kinderschminken kann
ich sagen wir tragen die gesichtswahrung
selbst auf einfach privat form
badezimmerspiegel ist der popmusik dabei
laufen kein kleber 54 feldjacke und der
pose und dann können sich hier im zelt
mal umziehen das so einigermaßen soldat
aussehen
jetzt habe ich mich umgezogen aber war
natürlich keine unterwäsche dran denn
jetzt geht es noch zum aufnahmerituale
oder wir haben
erst mal den ersten knopf auf oben also
jetzt doch schon richtung auf
[Musik]
wie viel munition haben wir jetzt was
wir bieten können wir können sich mit
pfeil und bogen verteidigen wird er auch
nicht geht theoretisch ohren geht
theoretisch aber wenn man sich unsere
waffen manchmal so anguckt was man
gehört wer pfeil und bogen manchmal
effektiver das nicht hier stand eben
doch ein kollege von extra 3
aber dann hat er schon wieder eine
dieser kritische fragen gestellt lernen
sie auch nie also das wäre jetzt die
kaserne wo ich wo theoretisch auch
einzigen könnte sozusagen oder sie
können natürlich wünsche äußern eine
frage noch ob ich dann auch das
lieblingsbild von mir und meinem opa
aufhängen dürfen könnte doch dann mit
meinem einer super aufhängung einfach
also definitiv nicht henkel über den
oliver welke auf das ist denke ich schon
dass die bundeswehr es doch nichts für
mich aber so ein panzer den kann ich gut
gebrauchen für die nächste
gehaltsverhandlung beim fernsehen
aufgeht
[Musik]